[Music]
so
[Music]
draft week is finally here and no better
way to close out this season of draft
crash course than with a round one mock
trap predicting what will happen
thursday night when we are live here in
the bleacher report app thursday friday
and saturday i'm the lead nfl draft
analyst here for vr connor rogers
alongside as always stadiums college
football analyst michael felder belder
all 32 picks of the first round we're
getting through them today we're taking
comments we're having fun we're going to
make fun of some teams as well how we
feeling let's close out this draft
season
no i love it man we got 32 teams we're
going to try to get in an hour might go
a little over but we've got some key
discussion points to hit on so conor
let's not waste any time let's get to
pick one let's get to the jags you tell
me how what your thought process is
behind as you make these picks
yeah right a lot of discussion around
the number one overall pick in this
draft we are just three days away and
nobody truly knows who it's going to be
the most recent favorite is trayvon
walker from georgia felder in this spot
i'm still going with aiden hutchinson
right now i think they're torn i think
they're a little torn in the front
office the coaching staff ownership here
and i think at the end of the day you
look at jacksonville they need players
right now and aiden hutchinson is not
your typical number one overall pick
although he can be a highly productive
edge rusher right away he can come in
across from josh allen and be
a threatening pass rusher that's
productive not just with sacks but
hurrying and pressuring the quarterback
consistently and stopping the run so
jacksonville here they go with the safer
option in this mock draft which felder
it might not get anybody excited as a
miles garrett or a chase young but you
have to agree this is what this
franchise needs right now correct
yeah stability someone that you know can
play there for seven eight years you're
not going to have to worry about getting
rid of him like this is a team that's
been through some tremendous turmoil and
some tremendous like up and down
up and down stakes so yeah get the safe
guy the safe guy is going to make you
going to make you happy he's going to
make fans happy he's going to be pretty
good in the communities as well so yeah
hutchinson at 1 makes sense because he's
a high floor player and we've talked
about this a ton of times high floor
players are the guys that don't get you
fired
high ceiling players that never reach
that ceiling are who gets you fired
well speaking of that felder that puts
us number two to the detroit lions they
would have loved to have aiden
hutchinson in this spot but no luck in
this situation maybe that will change on
thursday and they will go for the high
ceiling guy here in troyvon walker from
georgia only six and a half sacks last
year
a rare expected top three pick that was
never an ultra productive pass rusher at
the college level who is being drafted
to be an ultra productive pass rusher at
the nfl level something that you don't
typically see the measurables the
testing it's all off the charts he's an
excellent run defender you see how
smart patient and instinctive he can be
he can play inside he can play outside
but at the end of the day felder the
question mark is that i have with
trayvon walker and why he's my 20th
overall player not a top five player is
can he get there and can he get there
quickly and if you're the detroit lions
you're taking him at number two you're
expecting him to figure it out in the
next year
yeah that's the key is it's not can he
get there can you get him there and
that's what i'm looking forward to
watching because his development is
going to be really critical to the the
path of this franchise
as they figure out what their new
identity becomes uh because they're a
team that right now is still figuring
out who they are
all right number three the houston
texans one of the biggest wild cards in
the top 10 of this nfl draft and they
kind of fall with the theme here felder
they need good football players and that
is what icky iquanu is and you know
we'll see how long term that i know they
figured out the money with laramie
tunzel on the left side the right side
of their lines really shaky they
couldn't run the football last year
that's the name of the game ricky aquino
he's one of the best run blockers we've
seen in the draft over the last five
years i would say him and quentin nelson
are at the peak of that and he got a lot
better in pass for uh protection from
2020 to 2021. so felder you look at this
more of a building block pick we know
houston's front office with nick casario
coming from new england they build their
foundation usually in the trenches on
both sides of the ball this is one of
those safe and keep it steady kind of
selections
yeah literally i think about jeff
schwartz and duke manny weather the big
boy club and he's going to have a lot of
clips on there year one i'm glad you
brought up the clinton nelson comparison
not same position but same guy who's
just gonna go out there and be a bully
and you know what sometimes it's nice to
have a bully on your team and i think
that he can bring that to the table for
them
all right felder let's go to pick number
four which is where things get a little
interesting because if you and i were in
the gm chair in the driver's seat this
guy would be in contention to be the
number one overall pick but we have
heard no buzz about him being a threat
to go number one overall that's kayvon
thibodeaux a long time superstar he's
been a star since his freshman season at
oregon the jets need pass rush help i
know personally they have no fear of
these so-called character concerns or
anything along those lines they just are
a team that wants to get an impact
player in there that has the explosive
traits on their front floor to develop
so belder when you see kt
why is there such a projection forget
the fears why is there a projection that
he can be the best football player to
come out of this draft class
i mean look at the b-roll man look at
this guy he's covering a guy out of the
backfield running him down no problem
you see him there hand in the dirt look
at this
stands up the tackle then makes a tackle
i love this about him so for me he
checks every box i was talking to mark
dominic the former bucks gm he said he's
a little thin underneath uh he can get
stronger in the nfl but the strength has
never been a problem for him especially
with the way he's able to transition
speed to power so the question i kind of
kick back to you connor would be
you look at these three players in five
years
are we talking about kt we talking about
trayvon are we talking about aiden as
the best of the three because we have
three guys going to the top four in this
mop
for me it's it's kvontivido i go with my
evaluation right i look at it
kayvon thibodeau's my number two player
aiden hutchinson is number three and
then trayvon's number 20. there's more
projecting with him i think trayvon has
the highest floor as a run defender
because the way he's built
but i i just look at
kvon thibodeau's explosive nature
getting off the ball and you can't teach
that felder you can teach him to expand
that toolbox as a pass rusher work a
plan over four quarters of football get
in an nfl weight room and get stronger
in the lower half he's got the god-given
ability to do that but he comes with
things um that you just you can't teach
and i think that's why at the end of the
day if he puts in the work and goes to a
scheme like robert salo's attacking
front four he'll end up being the most
productive guy number five the giants
this is one of those steady eddie picks
as you would say felder you just need a
building block on the offensive line it
goes back to what the texans are doing
the giants though it's a little bit more
of a giveaway they have andrew thomas on
the left side now they take evan neal
fifth overall to play right tackle for
them and you know i've talked to some
offensive line coaches around the league
that actually like him better at right
tackle where he started in 2020 they
feel like he's got the feet for right
tackle not left tackle great drive
blocker
really good length and pass protection
felder this is probably one of the
safest players in the entire draft and
for a giants team that has missed a lot
in their previous regimes era that's
exactly what the doctor ordered
yeah uh just not missing is critical and
listen you're in new york city i've i've
spent so much time there i think i've
got the pulse of what how things work uh
from the jets and the giants standpoint
and
they just they don't want another eric
flowers
i think that's well
so i just i like his skills i mean
nobody this big should look that good
but he does and he gets the job done so
i'm looking forward to seeing if he's
the pick
does that mean that they're sold on
their quarterback situation if this is
the pick that they're making
yeah i think they've been vocal that
they're gonna they feel like they
haven't given daniel jones a fair shot
and whether that's right or wrong
they're gonna go out there and do that
with a new staff that'll be better than
what they've had working with him uh an
upgrade over jason garrett i would say
so and a better offensive line in front
of him and and we're gonna get to pick
number seven and see how that affects
them as well but pick number six for now
a team that you've been around quite a
bit before michael felder in those
carolina panthers
i think when you look at it this was the
pick i made that i kind of groaned and
said i don't want to do this and i do
that with a lot of pics that i'm
predicting not making for myself but
this is the one for this franchise that
they've been put in such a desperate
spot at quarterback the sam darnold
trade has not worked out and if they
don't take a shot on a guy this year
they might be in trouble in terms of job
security next year so kenny pickets the
pick here just because he's the i can
play right now of this quarterback class
i think at his best kenny pickett is a
derek carr caliber quarterback somebody
that can move a little bit outside the
pocket throw with anticipation go
through the faux field and get the ball
out now the question is what is the
upside the arm average the athleticism
average these are things that he's an
older quarterback right i mean he's
going to be a 24 year old quarterback
he's been in college for a long time so
felder i kick to you let's just assume
carolina feels internally they have to
go quarterback is this the right
decision
so here's a couple things one listen 704
i rep all day you know that but
can he pick it there's a couple i think
his arms above average based upon the
accuracy and that's part that's not that
listen does he have a cannon absolutely
not but he's got accuracy and i think
that's important he also doesn't make a
lot of bad throws which i think goes
into arm we don't always talk about it
that way but i think that goes into the
arm the other part i think is if
athleticism is above average we all saw
that when he put the brakes on and then
zoomed to the end zone in the acc
championship game so i think there's
some savviness that he that brings that
he brings to the table but the question
is and look the panthers gm or excuse me
panda's offensive coordinator was like
he's our starting sam darnold is our
starting quarterback and then
later in the interview he was like i
shouldn't have said that
i messed up sorry
didn't mean that um
so i think kenny pickett feels like a
safer choice i think when you have a guy
like matt rule who's on the hot seat all
right listen this is probably the most
panthers talk you're gonna get from a
national space but i'm gonna give it to
you because that's my hometown um
i think they are scared of picking
someone like malik willis that might
take two or three years to get it versus
someone like pickett because they don't
have two or three years to keep their
jobs
that's what it is felder it's job
politics in the nfl i can sit here and
make the argument from malik willis very
easily but the way we know the nfl and
how these things work when you go
through it it just seems like if they
can trade the pick and still get pick it
i know they'd love that i'm gonna be
honest guys nobody wants to come up in
this draft i'm just keeping it real no
matter how many teams a year want to
trade back trade back trade back
nobody's calling those phones right now
all right moving on to the giant
speaking of trade back they would answer
the phone for this pick but in this
situation we're not doing trades and
felder this is one of my
dream scheme fits in this draft sauce
gardener to the giants you got wink
martindale they are coming from
baltimore
cover zero cover one corners out on an
island can they press can they stay in
the hip pocket can they play man can
they stay and make a play on the
football sauce does all these things and
it's not just one year of tape doing
these things it's years of tape doing
these things the measurables the speed
you see the long spider type tentacle
arms makes a play right on the ball
right there he's a good tackler we've
talked about that a lot felder this is
one of those best player on the board
and a huge need for our franchise kind
of selections
no yeah we we love sauce here we don't
even have to talk that much sauce he's
good the guy's really good he's the best
corner in the draft love him obviously
some folks will talk about stingley
we'll get to stingley but i mean the
spider i mean look at how long his legs
are he's a short torso guy
short torso guy that's got wheels and he
he covers st he's got that
stick-to-itiveness that you're looking
for love him in that scheme
all right let's take a look at the
comments we'll take a little break here
after seven picks and we got some fun
because we got some questions submitted
not just written in the app and don't
worry i'm gonna get to those right after
this we got a video question so let's
get right to it
what's going on my name is tommy and my
question for you is what player that's
projected to go in the first round do
you think he's going to slide the
farthest in the draft bear
down
tommy gunn coming in with the heat right
there i like it now i saw something
interesting today a fringe first round
player has been kenyan green the tackle
guard from texas a m daniel jeremiah
from the nfl network recently said there
might be some medical concerns about a
need that could push him out of the
first round he is a first-round player
to me that when you hear things like
that the positional value if you only
value him as a guard if you have some
slight medical concerns he could fall
and for the bears they need offensive
line help and i think kenyan green would
be a slam dunk for that franchise we
know that they need help on offense
felder they have not done enough around
justin fields they need help in the line
if kenyan green falls i'd be willing to
roll the dice on that kind of risk
because i think he is plug and play and
would help a run heavy attack as well
felder who are you looking at that you
think could go in the first round you
could hear his name on today's show that
might slip to the bears and would make
sense
well you know when it comes to pick what
is it 39 uh you know i love jamari
sawyer there but i'm going to go with
george pickens another georgia player
right so we're going to talk about we're
going to be talking about them dogs a
little bit today and when i look at
george pickens because of the injury
issues and because of the production
situation you still don't know fully
what he can be and he had a spark for
the final four five six games uh two
years ago
uh with with uh jt jt daniels but at the
end of the day like we don't know what
he really is as a wide receiver compared
to especially guys whether it's a drake
london whether it's a crystal lava
whether it's any of these guys that have
been super productive so pickens is an
interesting one and i think that look if
he doesn't if he doesn't get picked up
in those first you know 38 picks he's
gonna be there because he's someone that
people still aren't sure about
and i think that's a great answer to the
question
fields to pick in something that should
have probably happened in georgia anyway
if the offense at georgia would have
been you know cohesive
yeah you can't always get what you want
there felder i agree that pickens should
be a more productive player at the nfl
level with better help in a passing
attack led by a quarterback that can get
him the ball all right so let's take a
break look at the comments real quick
steelers fan dink says not a single
quarterback worthy of a top 20 pick
felder and i have been preaching that on
this show for week after week wisco
fanatic said which teams
yeah yeah steelers at 20. could see
malik willis there wisco fanatic is
which teams do you think are the most
likely to trade down and up and another
one that pairs with that chase six is
eagles making another jump or falling
back felder i'll throw this to you with
the eagles moving up for jamison
williams to get speed alongside devonta
smith and jalen hurts makes sense to you
or do you like the value at wide
receiver by being patient instead
i think there's a lot of value at being
patient but other you mentioned it
though like
nobody really wants to move up nobody
wants to move up and so if nobody wants
to move up
and everyone wants to move down you're
not going to get real value by trying to
move up and so i think that the key is
and i i want to get to this because i
love your mock connor so i want to get
to it because where do where does james
actually come off the board can they get
him where they pick that's the question
because he's another guy coming off an
injury
all right well let's get right back into
it pick number eight and we're talking
wide receiver we got our first wide
receiver off the board here it's garrett
wilson to the falcons now i understand
jameis and williams got the speed i like
the floor gear wilson better felter i'm
just going to keep it real and i love
jameson williams he's my number two
receiver in this class but garrett
wilson that cd lam calvin ridley blend
of what he could do before and after the
catch the falcons need a bonafide target
that can eat number one targets and can
do it pretty quickly they can't really
sit around and be patient i understand
they're rebuilding but you still need a
guy to come in there and be the guy
alongside kyle pitt so he's not getting
bracket coverage week after week after
week so garrett wilson i'll say this
spell there he might not excite people
the most in the strap like drake london
or jameson williams but if i was an
evaluator and just wanted the guy that i
know was going to be a high caliber
receiver and pretty quickly he'd be the
one i'd stick my name on
no i i love he's great and this is the
thing this is the beauty of doing
recruiting connor is i've seen him play
pre pre-college go into college and
still do the same things at the next
level and then continue to do them so i
expect him to continue to do them at the
next level and so the big thing for me
with him is
he's this guy's been a pro forever this
is he's born to do this he was made to
do this he was groomed to do this he's
ready for it i think you're getting a
professional and
as we talk about atlanta we're we're
we're literally talking about a team
that
they need somebody that can step in and
play right now i think he is the answer
you see the comment right there from
chuck bucks is atlanta we should pick
hamilton if available i know michael
felder would like that but i would love
to go garrett wilson you can't go wrong
you get a cornerstone on defense or a
cornerstone on offense atlanta
they need both those things see you
can't go wrong in that selection those
would be both the a uh graded picks for
me number nine seattle seahawks picking
here after the big russell wilson trade
felder this is a little bit of a roll of
the dice but i'm hearing he's climbing
back up boards now that he was able to
test and looks healthy derek stingley
comes off the board seattle needs
corners stingley has a ton of upside we
know what he can do in man coverage we
know what he can do as a tackler we know
what he can do when he's on to take away
the football
felder talk me through a little bit of
the risk reward with one of the most
polarizing players in the entire draft
it's about him being on the field i mean
he's just got to be on the field that's
the big key and
he like you see here slow diagnosis
recognize and then go make a play he can
make that tackle that's fantastic
i just want to see more of him from a
zone standpoint because that's a lot of
what seattle likes to do is still play
zone they play man but they also play a
lot of zone so yeah i think that that's
going to be critical and it's important
he's got diagnosis ability he can do all
those things but i just want to see him
consistently do it and we haven't got a
chance to watch that because he didn't
really play a year ago and that's going
to be the part can we stay on the field
can we stay healthy you run a 4-3 and i
love it i love it i think stingley is a
great a phenomenal player
i just i when you get into the zones
like the biggest issue for lsu not to
take us into the college path but was it
they had guys on different pages all the
time because everyone was like i play
man i came here to play man and then
they're like well we're trying to play
cover two right now and
that doesn't jibe so i think the key for
him is just gonna be making sure that
he's you know crossing his t's and
dotting his eyes but he's a tremendous
player and a remarkable athlete as long
as he stays healthy
all right pick number 10 the new york
jets are back on the clock if they sit
tight here felder it's got to be a wide
receiver to get zach wilson some help
and we're going to go with drake london
in the spot a jump ball target above the
rim player that small forward wide
receiver that can win the 50 50 balls
turn him into 80 20. he blocks he's
strong after the catch and he's a better
route runner than giving credit for i
think because it looks clunkier because
he's 6'3 plus and gonna play around 215
pounds it doesn't look the same as a 5
foot 10 speedster getting open but right
there you see the ability to create
enough space to put himself in position
to out jump the target
to out jump the defensive back the
tracking for drake london zach wilson he
loves to play outside of the pocket he
needs somebody that can come back and
win the football that makes trick london
in play here for the jets
yeah well it also looks clunkier because
his quarterback threw air balls like
what are we doing like
like
and this is like this is a perfect combo
though right conor because
with zach wilson when i think about zach
wilson in college a lot of times he was
throwing back shoulder phase because his
wide receivers couldn't get all the way
open and he didn't push it over the top
all the time because his guys weren't
creating separation vertically they were
creating separation horizontally with a
push off to go find a way to catch a
back shoulder fader and find a way to
catch it on on par ball
drake has the ability to go vertical to
get ahead of you so now wilson can push
the ball more over the top which should
lead to bigger plays instead of having
to throw back shoulders so there's all
these things that are working in concert
and i'm excited like this dude obviously
the basketball background is important
but the the big thing for me is that
body like the big body
i as a deep as a back i'm more worried
about a guy that i can't stop than a guy
that i can't run with
if you're faster than me jameson
williams or tyreek hill we're going to
put a safety over the top right we're
going to do something to help me to help
shield me but if you're just i'm faster
than you or we're the same speed and
then i don't get help and he can just
kind of push me around and make a play
that to me is more that's the whole
definition of mossing someone it wasn't
just that randy moss outran people it
said he took the ball away from
defensive back so they're in prime
position and i think drake london's got
a little bit of that ability
i'm with you fella there's nothing
scarier than a guy that's open when he's
covered all right recap in the top 10
aiden hutchinson went first overall the
jacksonville trayvon walker goes number
two to the lions three icky aquarium to
the texans for kayvon thibodeau to the
new york jets five evan neal to the new
york giants six kenny pickett to the
carolina panthers seven the new york
giants again taking sauce gardener man
cover corner atlanta falcons on the
clock at number eight take garrett
wilson our first wide receiver off the
board number nine the seattle seahawks
take derek stingley and 10 the jets back
on the clock get the guy we just broke
down in drake london let's take a look
at the comments before we move outside
the top ten picks of this draft
derek beyer says falcons dead set on
rolling with mariota haven't seen many
projecting them to go quarterback so
felder i will throw this to you it's
been very quiet on the falcons who
traded matt ryan this offseason
everything we hear is that they're going
to kick the quarterback can down the
road
but what if we did get a surprise on
draft night and they felt like they do
you think that's the right environment
for malik willis to sit behind marcus
mariota for maybe a year long term he'd
be looking to throw to kyle pitts he's
got corduroy patterson there maybe they
get another receiver in that room as
well i i we always talk about
guys landing with teams and how that
impacts the team how do you like the fit
for malik willis to atlanta
i honestly i think they're stuck between
kind of a rock and a hard place in that
spot because they need a receiver right
now their their best receiver is not
playing
they need one but
to me
that's a city
that would welcome malik willis with
open arms like he would be
vic too like they would love him they
would love for him to be the face of
that franchise so i think they're in a
tough spot there because
we've got to like if we don't get a
receiver we won't have one like we just
won't have one our guy got he got caught
on
fanduel or whatever it was and now we're
in trouble so
it's literally like we need a guy
so
they they're stuck between a rock and a
hard place but certainly if you're if
let's be real connor if you're looking
across the entire landscape of the nfl
and somewhere from malik wants to go
atlanta's got to be in the top three or
four
i think so i think it makes a lot of
sense it's just a matter of how far will
he fall and have they kept their cards
close to the vest we will see so really
good question from derek fire there g
ferguson says can't go wrong with any of
the offensive tackles
i completely agree with that take but
this is a good offensive tackle class
and 836 says the texans need to take a
db and pass rusher in the first round
we'll see what they do at 13. you might
be onto something pick number 11
washington commanders on the clock here
felder and i'm gonna let you take the
floor because
this is my landing spot for kyle
hamilton run away with it
i love him he's good you're getting a
steal this is for me he's a top four
player in this draft i think he's
remarkable uh we're gonna see it here
look at the range he's on the hash and
let's go let's run take it away from him
baby let's do it and that's against
alabama and i know it's slayed bolton
but i don't care then you see him there
coming down into the box so we've seen
him move laterally we've seen him move
down we've seen him be physical we've
seen him be aggressive look at the way
he covers all that ground he's a long
strider as you like to say conor i i
just think that his game is is so
complete i don't care what his 40 time
is because at the end of the day when
you see a guy
run from the right hash all the way to
the left sideline and make an
interception
on a play that should have been a
touchdown you know that he understands
what's happening before it happens and
that gives you an extra half second on
on what you're doing this is a big
pickup for them cornerstone of that
defense obviously r.i.p sean taylor like
this is that they're this can be their
next great safety
yeah i mean he's somebody felter that he
covers ten yards differently than some
than a normal human being with those
strides it is unbelievable and that
sideline run defense uh it makes a big
difference all right let's bundle the
next two picks 12 we have the vikings
and they're going to go jermaine johnson
13 we have the texans they're going to
go george carloftus so we have a little
bit of a pass rush run here 12 with the
vikings looking at jermaine johnson one
of the biggest risers of the entire year
a former juco kid then makes his way to
georgia develops at georgia not a lot of
people talk about that he developed at
georgia he wanted to play more he goes
to florida state he was right he was one
of the best players in college football
this year turned into an absolute star
double-digit sax he goes to the senior
bowl two days of practice there was not
a single human being on the field that
can block him so now we're starting to
see the next tier of pass rushers come
off the board here felder let's start
with jermaine johnson and what he can do
going into a situation where they have
the neil hunter they sign zadarius smith
but he's the next guy up and those three
rushing on passing downs is a terrifying
sight
well that's the thing you can kick one
inside and then let him go but we see
him stand up in this clip
we see him we see him stand up in this
clip we see him hand down this clip we
see him do all those things so he can do
everything that you want and look push
to the inside push through to the inside
that's beautiful football i love that
about him i really have been excited
watching jermaine johnson be able to get
out there and get the job done because
it was a long road to college football
and he still got the job done
all right 13 already teased that george
karloftis another pass rusher he's
coming off the board to the texans we
saw the comments the texans fans looking
for pass rush help they don't get it at
three they can get it right here in
carloftus now i would like to classify
karloff is more as that high floor run
defender and effort rusher i like his
first step i think his change of
direction is a little questionable at
times that might stop him from ever
being a double-digit sack guy when
you're looking at somebody that can play
with his hand in his dirt contain stop
the run you see the turn the corner
there it's impressive at the size and
the weight he carries the lower body
power carloftus he might not be the
flashiest pass rusher in this draft but
he once again falls into that category
as safe felder
no i agree sorry about that man i don't
know my uh my my girl went crazy over
here a-l-a-l-e-x-a
she went nuts so i guess she's excited
about jermaine johnson
going to the vikings uh for the texas
yeah he's safe this guy is really good i
i love watching carlotta's play he's
someone that's really willing to come
he's
to me he is
he feels like a throwback football
player does that make sense or he's
someone who is going to sit in a 4-3
he's going to play your front side and
and he's going to take he's going to
absorb that that bro the brunt of the
run game be able to disengage set an
edge and then when you need him to he
can rush the passer as well
yeah felder i kind of want to see george
karloftis in a t-bar face mask now i
think it would be very fitting to the
style that he plays football so carlatas
buy into it let's go to the comments but
before we do that
let's go to a video comment i heard the
texans fans are loud and proud let's
check it out
is there a fifth or even a sixth year
senior in college i got to stay an extra
year because of the coveted rule that no
one's talking about that could come in
and make an impact in the nfl who do
y'all have y'all's eyes on
thanks texas community what's up
awesome question there that had us
thinking there are a lot of players that
had a fifth or sixth year because the
covet eligibility and i know he said
instant impact and unfortunately the
player that i like did get hurt during
his pro day if not for that he would
have made an instant impact at a minimum
on special teams that's clint ratkovic
the northern illinois superback is what
he is now rakovich has been in college
since 2017. so he's been around for a
really really long time and here you see
him at his first stop uh in college the
ability to catch the ball block run just
do it all he's a fullback but in this
league you can't just be a fullback
anymore that's not the way the nfl has
gone you need to be able to be a
versatile piece a player that can make
things happen with and without the ball
in his hands so rakovich uh you know
cheers to him getting healthy hopefully
that he can come back towards the end of
the year if not the end of the year be
stashed somewhere and then make an
impact in 2023.
felder i think you're leaning the same
way looking in the backfield who's a
player that you like that took advantage
of the extra eligibility
yeah i go ty chandler right like listen
last year unc lost a lot in the run game
sam howell had to run for 800 and
something yards ty chandler came over
from tennessee as a grad transfer this
is a guy that capitalized on it he
showed that he can catch the ball in the
backfield he's got some good ability to
finish runs i love his ability to run
inside to get outside and then once he
hits the corner he's fast enough to be a
problem so i think ty chandler belongs
in the mix as well he was sam basically
sam howell's only helping the run game
if we're being quite honest and he was
able to get the job done coming over to
a new team so i'm gonna go with ty
chandler a guy that played five years
and and really
capitalize on what he was able to do
both at tennessee and then at unc
all right felder let's get back to the
draft and i promise these guys did not
have to play for five years they were
able to get out whenever they needed to
let's start at pick 14. the baltimore
ravens are on the clock they need beef
in the middle of this defense we just
saw a run on pass rushers and car loftus
and jermaine johnson go either those
guys would have played for the ravens so
instead we're gonna look on the interior
here felder and go jordan davis the big
man uh the bigger vince wilfork is what
i think he is he can two gap he can eat
a lot of space he can keep blockers off
of the guys next to you and for the
ravens this is where they need help
it'll help their run defense i think
he's going to be able to stay on the
field even longer at the nfl level maybe
create some effort rushing ability but
what he does to open things up for the
guys around him is where he makes the
most money
yeah well the thing i wanted to ask you
is
is this a raven specific pick
because
it feels like not a lot of teams are
after jordan davis so is this raven
specific knowing kind of their their
history with whether it's terrence cody
hello dinada like they this feels like a
very raven specific pick is it am i
crazy for saying that
no you're spot on i i said earlier this
week that
you know the old cliche he just feels
like a baltimore raven in that black and
purple which is so dumb to say but it's
just it's true with him because these
are the guys we're used to seeing in the
middle of that defense and they stay
true to their roots and uh you just
there's not a lot of humans built like
jordan davis fell there
no there's not there are not a lot of
there are not a lot of guys that are
that big that move that well so yeah
good pick for them i love it
all right 15 the philadelphia eagles we
talked a little earlier about how maybe
they can come up in this draft for this
player if he doesn't make it here
jamison williams is the pick for the
eagles they need speed at wide receiver
they need somebody that compliments
devonta smith this is going to help the
passing game with jalen hurts this is
one of the best run heavy teams in
football felder now you add jameson
williams the threat of jameson williams
into the equation that's only going to
make you better as a running team as
teams cannot stack the box they need to
dedicate a lot of help towards this guy
so they're going to be a little patient
i know he's already out there working
out moving around he might be back
earlier than people think but felder
this is kind of the argument that we
just had with the previous pick there
aren't a lot of humans like jordan davis
with his size and his athleticism there
aren't a lot of humans like jameson
williams that run in the four twos with
polish
yeah he's that the polish is the part
that gets me because i don't care if he
ran a 4-4 he'd still be super good at
wide receiver because of the way that he
stims inside to get outside or stands
outside to get inside he does all these
things he can fade he buys himself space
to the sideline to fade away from the
defender to create space for the
quarterback to hit him i love what he
brings to the table he is heat for me
he's my wide receiver number one we've
talked about this over the course of the
other nine shows that we've done he's my
wide receiver number one for all the
nuance that goes into his his his route
running and all those little things his
his dedication to the craft i'm looking
forward to listen you get in there you
get him the opportunity to go out and
make these plays uh man just good grief
i mean what are the eagles becoming uh
alabama north
that's what it looks like all right the
saints they picked twice now in the
first round thanks to that trade with
the eagles and they're gonna go charles
cross here felder this is a little bit
of a fall for cross he's a top 10 player
for me they need to tackle after losing
tyron armstead i like this fit for both
sides i look at cross and think he's
kind of a cannonball run blocker i love
what he can do north to south i think
the pass protection he's so athletic
that he can recover really well i think
he's got a little get a little bit
stronger on the outside rushes uh keep
that strong shoulder run guys out wide
but it's all there for him to be a
cornerstone for a long time and this is
the number one see uh need on the saints
board to protect jameis winston
well the thing is he's super athletic i
mean he's got that kind of cliche
basketball build right like he's built
like a power forward we here get thrown
around all the time but when you look at
him play that's exactly what he has the
way that he can flat back and go make
plays is great he's athletic enough to
get out and run in that screen game as
we've seen here you see him there look
at that flat back again he knows what
he's doing he understands i got to get
up underneath here get get into this
chest plate and then i can rock and roll
and i can control you no matter where i
need to go he doesn't have the power of
icky or evan neil doesn't need it
because he understands what's happening
to him he's a really good offensive
lineman so yeah across to the saints i
absolutely love it
yeah i'll say this about cross too he's
not your typical mike leach offensive
lineman he was not recruited by that
regime he is an old-school uh powerhouse
kind of left tackle right tackle
wherever he's going to play at the next
level in this scenario for the saints he
plays on the left side all right keeping
things moving the chargers are on the
clock at 17.
and now there's been a little run on
wide receiver here felder i'm gonna go
with the last top-tier corner and that's
trent mcduffie they care so much about
this defense they signed jc jackson to
big money they have derwin james they've
added a lot up front they have khalil
mack joey bosa this unit is loaded i
think they still need one more corner
and you bring in mcduffie throw ready
pro smarts great eyes great awareness
can plant and drive downhill uh the best
zone corner in the entire draft he loves
the tackle he used to ask his coaches
all the time can i play safety and run
down the alley that you know they would
say hey can you stay a corner so he's
just an awesome player an awesome person
and he kind of fits that identity for
the chargers starting to build a
powerhouse defense at all three levels
in the field
well the scariest part is this is him
covering guys across the field a lot of
it right and when you can cover guys all
the way across the field that means
you've got some speed too i don't care
what the numbers say the reality of it
is you can if you cover across the field
you understand angles and you anticipate
what's going to happen so i love that
about him and the big key for me you
mentioned that he plays well in zone
this guy's well taught and he is
certainly a technician we had him in our
technician around a week ago right
thursday we talked about him as a
technician this guy can really play he
understands how to take his drops he
doesn't spot drop he drops to match what
players are going to do and then in man
coverage if you want to bring him across
the formation he's going to beat you to
the spot and then he's one of the best
tacklers he's going to get you down on
the ground so yeah love mcduffie coming
out of washington washington over the
last few years they have had a lot of
guys that have made impacts at that at
the secondary level and he's just going
to be the next one of those guys
all right 18 the eagles are back on the
clock and felder this is one of my
favorite coverage chess pieces of the
entire draft man it's dax hill one of my
favorite players in the entire draft
because he could play the slot he could
play too high he could play single high
he could do whatever you ask him to do i
mean it's the old booby miles he could
walk the dog paint the back porch
run kick do everything that's dax hill
is that kind of back end defender he
could tackle he's a great tester man the
eagles are one of those teams that they
would love one of the top three corners
in this draft it didn't work out for
them that way stingley sauce mcduffie
they're all gone don't sleep on sauce
gardner coming in and really being a
corner in his own way that has the
luxury of being a ball hawking safety as
well so felder these are usually your
kind of guys in the draft what have you
seen from jackson hill
i mean we just saw daxel cover across
the formation now we're going to see him
sink into coverage okay i'm sinking into
coverage now i'm coming up to fill it
okay you're not gonna get a first down
there now let's like he can do he can do
everything i think dax hill is i called
him a swiss army knife right this is a
guy you mentioned one high uh one single
high too high plus the inside slot he's
also played outside corner in their
cover zero that barefront package that
they use for short yardage and been able
to shut those guys down i love him i
think he's great i don't need like we
don't have to go on and on about him the
guy is fantastic and what you're getting
is a player that
is going to fit anywhere in the defense
you find a weakness in your defense and
he's going to be a guy that can repair
it from a secondary level
all right let's go to the comments
aslanco says i don't see charles cross
being on the board past 10. you never
know but i agree with you across the top
10 player in this draft mkent93 says
felder's beard on point once again tune
in thursday friday and saturday for the
studio beard that's right that's what
you want to see is the studio beard all
right let's get into one more here
scrolling scrolling scrolling there was
a saints question a divisor says who's
another possibility if cross is gone for
the saints i think they'd like trevor
penning but let's waste no time and get
into pick 19 because they pick again so
here's another possibility if they don't
go tackle belder it's chris a lobby this
is just one of those it's easy it makes
too much sense in the offense they run
he's smooth he knows how to get open he
tracks the ball down the field jameis
winston is their quarterback jameis
winston is going to be their quarterback
he knows how to throw the ball in the
intermediate area he knows how to push
the ball vertically we've seen a lava do
this for years he can come in line up
across from michael thomas he could
stretch the field he could beat you on
the paper cut routes
a lava is this is kind of where the wide
receiver run is going to get a little
scary for the teams after them so the
saints make out like bandits in this
scenario
yeah i think when we see a lava go off
the board and this is less about the
saints and more about the wide receiver
position
once we see a lava go off the board that
probably means that london williams and
um garrett wilson are already off the
board which means oh everyone's thinking
oh crap
what are we gonna do next which elave
could be kind of the harbinger for guys
like jahan dotson david bell skye moore
to
see themselves be bumped up and you see
a lave there the body control is amazing
so i think he's a pivotal point when it
comes to wide receivers in this draft
all right pick number 20 another pivotal
point the steelers they don't have to go
up to get him malik willis falls into
their lap this team loves malik willis
and i get it right you've built an
infrastructure that malik willis can
come in develop and thrive he's going to
sit behind mr biski you got your veteran
starter there you got weapons you have
naji harris the offensive line needs a
little bit of work but maybe they can
continue that on day two of this draft
after spending some dollars there in
free agency we've talked about malik
willis a lot we've talked about him at
six of the panthers we've talked about
him at eight to the falcons in this
scenario he does fall a little bit
felder but i think it's in his best
interest to go to a spot like this where
you view him as the long-term franchise
guy but you allow him to marinate just a
little bit to season right to be the
superstar that a lot of people think
those raw traits can turn into
look at you talking cooking you're
speaking my language my man and uh i
love it malik willis is a he's super
talented amazing arm strength anyone
that says he's a running back that that
plays quarterback is crazy they haven't
watched him play because what he can do
with his arm is remarkable and so the
the key for me is going to be giving him
a little bit of time to grow into it and
again we talked about it with the
panthers that's time isn't a luxury that
this team has afforded tomlin is someone
who has been afforded the luxury of time
so he has the ability to do this take a
quarterback that's a little bit on the
shorter side but has a tremendous arm
has the ability to improv and can find
his way and you have the luxury of
having trubisky in there to take the
fire in front of him so that malik wills
isn't the guy that's having his
confidence destroyed so i love it uh
connor let's let's get to the comments
and kind of recap these top 20 picks
because we're we only got 12 to go man
yeah we're flying right now let's recap
11 through 20 a fun run is what i would
like to call it a lot of players that
are worthy of top 10 picks or top 10
players to me going here starting with
kyle hamilton to the commanders at 11.
jermaine johnson to the vikings at 12.
those are both top 10 players on my
board george karloftis had 13 to the
texans jordan davis 14 to the ravens
jameson williams my wide receiver 2
felder's wide receiver 1 15 to the
eagles charles cross my third tackle a
top 10 player to the saints at 16. trent
mcduffie my number two corner in this
class guys the third corner off the
board 17 to the chargers daxton hill one
of felder and i's absolute favorites in
this strap swiss army coverage piece for
the philadelphia eagles chris alabe the
wide receiver run going crazy to the
saints at 19. malik willis through the
steelers at 20 they are jumping for joy
that they don't have to move him up guys
have you loved watching crash course
with felder and i for weeks now for
months at this point
we're not done here we gotta cap this
thing off with our draft night special
you see it right there day one day two
day three we are covering every single
pick from rounds one through five the
three days of the draft you see me
felder hosted by adam lefkow special
guest richard sherman thursday and
friday jason kelsey thursday and friday
i'm on ross st brown thursday and friday
and then tori holt coming in on saturday
to break things down with felder and i
that is a loaded crew we're gonna be
asking richard sherman about dbs jason
kelsey on the o line i'm on raw saint
brown about a loaded wide receiver class
and then the legend torrey hull for day
three of the draft so we're excited here
let's get back to the picks we got new
england on the clock at pick 21
and manfelder
it's time it's time to do it again we've
done this over and over again i'm going
devin lloyd here for new england they
like a certain kind of linebacker they
like the guys with flame devin lloyd 6'3
he's going to play around 240 245. sure
he's not a contact monster but he can do
enough coming downhill sideline to
sideline coverage they'd like their
linebackers to rush a little bit too he
can do that with his hand in the dirt so
felder i know you are team the kobe dean
and i get it i love nicoby dean i think
he's going to be the best pick of the
top of the second round but devin lloyd
just screams new england linebacker a
position that not a lot of teams in the
nfl put a premium on anymore but bill
belichick always will
yeah listen i'd love to see dean in this
spot and we'll talk dean later but the
big key for me is you you hit on it they
like their linebackers to rush a little
bit and he can do that and i think
that's the part that makes him a little
bit uh scary not not russia's in blitz
but russia's in i can put my hand down
on third and 12 and i'll just come off
the edge and go make a play so i'd love
that about uh lloyd's game obviously
listen no kyle whittingham is a heck of
a football coach y'all he is really good
specifically when it comes to the
defensive side of the ball and the way
that his guys always come into the
league and make impact and and show
themselves is critical i like there's
not you can't argue with the pick i
would pick dean but with devin lloyd the
patch are going to get exactly what they
want a long-armed freak that can put his
hand in the dirt and rush the
quarterback on third and 12.
all right 22 green bay packers on the
clock and folks it finally happens they
get aaron rodgers a wide receiver here
it's treylen burks they can't wait
felder they can't wait until 28 they
can't get cute with this you got to get
a guy that can make an impact
burke's the the opinions on him are all
over the board on this show we obviously
love him he can win down the field on
the outside he can be a big slot on
catch and run touches he can be a gadget
player here you see him outside right
went down the field just throw me the
football throw me the football i'm
bigger than this guy i'm stronger than
this guy i come down with the ball you
see right here the ability get to the
outside pylon and make an easy jump ball
cap this is what burks can do you can
make life easier on the quarterback with
the ball in the air you can do it with
the catch and run ability the build up
speed felder aaron rodgers has got to be
happy when this guy walks through the
door from for mini camp this summer
yeah i mean i i want it to happen i just
i don't know if they're going to do it
they haven't done it so we'll see what
happens i love his build up speed and we
didn't get to show the clips against
alabama where he's run away from the
alabama player so this is going to be an
interesting one
yes should they pick a wide receiver
absolutely if you've got one of the best
people to ever pick up at football and
throw it maybe give them some more help
but we'll see if they actually do it
that's the question it's not if this is
a good pick for them the question is
will they actually do it
all right so we're going to package
these next two picks together and we
will see on draft night if the packers
finally do it very up in the air 23 and
24 23 the cardinals guard zion johnson
24th dallas cowboys guard canyon green
this is our little guard run right here
let's start right there pick 23 with the
arizona cardinals
it's got to be better in front of kyler
murrayfelder it's this team's got to be
able to run the ball they got to be able
to protect their quarterback they got to
be able to get him to buy in that
they're doing everything around him
which they've done a good job of in my
opinion but this keeps that moving
zion's played left tackle he's played
left guard he's thrived at guard he took
some snaps at center at the senior bowl
this interior has to be better felder
and this is a guy that's played a lot of
football at the college level level
after being a no-name recruit you see
the player comparison right there and
ally marpette
he really really gets the job done week
in and week out
yeah i'll go quick here um you think
both of these guys have played all over
the offensive line connor are we we're
solid that they're going to play guards
and then guards that could maybe in a
pinch kick out the tackle
yeah i think that's it's just key right
it gives you a little insurance right
there and you're going to see that now
with kenyan green as well right as we
transition to the cowboys kenyon green
is somebody that
has played left tackle right tackle left
guard right guard now i think zion is
truly a guard at the next level where
kenyon green there's a little bit more
flexibility but felder i'll say this and
i know you watch as much college
football as anyone canyon green's best
games no coincidence always seemed to be
when they let him get comfortable at
guard over the long term am i crazy
no you're not crazy i think that's right
i think he works better being kind of
protected on either side and being able
to be and that protection allows him to
be a little more aggressive and that's
what i see when i watch him play you're
going to see this play right here where
look he's not worried about the outside
he's worried about the inside and then
he's able to maul against mizzou so i
think that you're spot on with that you
see it again here watch the way that
he's able to get more aggressive and
then climb to the second level i like
that about him he has that ability so
yeah i think you're spot on i just am
curious to see if these teams are maybe
over drafting a guard thinking they can
move him to tackle when the reality is
you should be really happy with either
of these guys playing at the guard
position
i'm with you felder take the guys that
can come in plug and play be your guards
for the long term and if you need them
in a pinch to kick out it's like elijah
vera tucker last year right everybody
was like oh how can you take a guard
this early the jets traded up for a
guard that early and we knew he could
play tackle because he did it at the
college level but he found a lot of
success at guard as a rookie let's get
to the comment section right here pete
rodriguez says saints love ohio state
wide receivers
uh bc night six felder likes our eagles
haul jameson williams and daxton hill is
a great hall i think a lot of people
will be happy with that one m ken says
steelers will definitely trade up for
willis i agree uh lou steve 77 says
lloyd is solid and somehow new england
always maximizes draft pick production
that is something that felder and i have
talked a lot about landing spot goes a
long way for the players and what these
staffs can get out of them or what some
staffs unfortunately cannot all right
back to the comments here
first of a surprise and this is
definitely a
what i think they will do rather than
what what i would do the bills take
brees hall right so the bills take
priests hall our first running back off
the board our only round one running
back
a guy i've compared to deuce mcallister
an elite athlete at the position of
elder he's got size
if you listen to brandon bean speak
about this team they want to take the
mileage off josh allen's legs during the
regular season the constant hits the
constant running it's still going to be
a big part of his game but they want a
workhorse runner that can come in and
thrive as this downhill guy
obviously this this bell cow back felder
when you look at brees hall there's
going to be a lot of crowd that responds
negatively to a first round running back
but i'm comfortable that he's here what
do you see with his game that tells you
he's worthy of at least a top 40
pick uh the ability to catch the ball of
the backfield is is is one thing right
so we're going to see him catch the ball
out of the backfield great no problem
make a guy make the first guy miss make
another guy miss and then get up field
and go make a play he's a he can run
between the tackles he's not afraid he
likes to do it there's great balance to
his game i was talking to mark dominic
the former
bucks gm and he also mentioned
hall
as one of those guys and isaiah spiller
as well as a possible target for the
bills because they know they want to
shore up that that rushing attack don't
know if it happens in the first round or
the second round but certainly hall for
me is running back number one you see
him here with the burst and that build
up speed we mentioned with burke's where
once he gets going downhill if you're
not going to touch him he's going to run
away from you so i love the idea of hall
going in the first round i think the guy
is tremendous i think if iowa state had
lived up to that top 10 uh ranking that
they had pre-season breese hall probably
would be it would be a no-brainer that
he's a first runner i think because
their season was uh largely uh not a
disappointment but their season didn't
go the way people expected or wanted it
to go that he's got one of those guys
that we saw slip same thing with charlie
kohler at the tight end spot
all right 26 the titans are on the clock
and they go with tyler smith the hulking
hulking left tackle from tulsa felder
this is the definition of road grader
this is the door frame width this is the
you're in front of me you're going in
the dirt and you're going to watch him
here just the ability to move get his
hands on people take them out of the
play it's very easy for this guy the
technique is not there the hand
placement at times you see right there
all the way on top of the shoulder pads
he's just so strong it doesn't matter
felder and the titans they can play him
at guard right away they can move him
over to right tackle he fits that
downhill get derek henry rolling down
the tracks kind of scheme
yeah that's what i was gonna say like
this is a this is purely a derrick henry
pick of a guy that can wash down an
entire side of an offensive line uh when
they get into
listen the key for them is going to be
don't lose don't be losing you can't be
down by two scores in the fourth quarter
or this guy's gonna have problems
staying in the football game but if
you're on top and your run game is
cooking now this is the guy you want
because all you have to do is point him
in the right direction and he's going to
get going
all right 27 one of my favorite picks in
this entire mock draft because i love
this player lewis scene to the bucks it
feels like a cheat code the buck's a
loaded roster already getting a player
like lewis scene now i know people at
home are thinking they got a lot of dbs
they sign logan ryan in the offseason do
a one-year deal todd bowles loves his
safeties folks this is a man that
drafted jamal adams with the top 10 pick
and then came back around in the top 40
to take marcus may he's always thinking
three years ahead with his safeties seen
incredible downhill good awareness and
coverage over the top super super
athlete he just runs around like a
missile felder and if you let a guy like
this kind of freelance in a defense that
already has two safeties you say hey
you're our third guy we're gonna play
you in the box we're gonna use you over
the top at times it's kind of a dream
scenario it's a luxury that a lot of
teams do not have
yeah he's great in the box and he's
great coming downhill uh i'm glad we
showed the first play though which was
him
basically recognizing a double pass when
nobody else saw it and
uh going and taking the ball away
obviously here
seize the ball see ball see quarterback
see ball go get ball
he's got the ability to do all those
things so yeah i love lewiston i think
he's amazing i i love that he's kind of
bubbled up to the surface people were
talking about him early as a day two
player and now all of a sudden we're
seeing him uh pop up a lot of places a
day one ball ball player so he is
i mean here's the reality he's a
punisher too and that's something that
we didn't see in those clips we saw him
playing in pass coverage but you go back
and watch this guy against the run and
it's like he takes a personal affront to
the fact that you thought you were gonna
run the ball to where he's supposed to
be and he makes you pay he will saw you
off he will chop you down he will go
face to face on you and you're gonna
feel it today all day and tomorrow and
that's what i love about his game he
brings some attitude as an enforcer
yeah for anyone that hasn't seen it when
we're done here do a little youtube of
lewis scene meets kyle pitts and you
will see what felder is talking about it
is
bananas all right right there atl says
seen definitely the best safety behind
hamilton that's how it goes on my board
he's a first round player i think that
gap is a lot closer than a lot of people
realize all right 28 the green bay
packers one more pick before we go to
the comments devonta wyatt here felder
the packers are a team that they'll
always place a premium on that defensive
line they do have a little bit of a need
on the interior i know they've made some
additions in free agency but long term
this is value here wyatt often viewed as
a top 20 player takes a little bit of a
dive here a 24 year old kind of breakout
player but for green bay they're trying
to win a super bowl right now and you're
telling me
kenny clark davonte wyatt rashaan gary
preston smith all in the same defensive
line that'll play for the packers
yeah that dog hunts all day uh no pun
intended with him going to georgia and
being a bulldog but he's the guy that we
can we've seen line up at a zero we've
seen a lot of bit of one or two or three
seen him play all the way out to the
four eye and he's got the ability to do
all those things so yeah this is a great
pick for me he's my number one defensive
tackle in this draft and he's not you
listen if he can't get to the
quarterback he'll get his hands up you
see him there lined up in that spot boom
don't worry i'm going to work laterally
and then i'm gonna disengage and make a
play so i i think that wyatt has he
checks every box this guy is
a cat man
all the words that i say are coming up
again i was gonna say this guy's a
bulldog but like he is a bulldog because
he played for georgia but i mean he's a
bulldog like he's a tenacious fighter
when it comes to the game so yeah love
this pick you're going to get a guy
that's going to consistently make plays
in green bay
all right let's go to the comments one
more time jay byrne and tell which says
are the vikings a potential destination
for malik willis at 12. felder if kirk
cousins under contract for two years
you think that's a situation that you
take a quarterback this year
no not in the first round at least i
don't think so
i think that i think they're a team
that's gonna they're gonna as you
mentioned kick the can down the road if
you can get a guy in the second round
maybe that's a sam howell uh maybe
that's a carson strong maybe you do that
give them some time to kind of learn and
grow but i don't think in the first
round that's an answer
all right keeping it moving mbryan 5
says jerry jones won't be able to keep
himself from trading up for treylon
traelin burks
i would not be shocked they're a team
that invests heavily in the offensive
line of course in recent history or at
least the last half decade plus but
traelin burks we know the cowboys are
all over that pick let's get back to the
draft let's finish out the last four
picks and then we will spend some time
in the comments before we sign off
29 felder the chiefs they got back to
back picks here we're going to kick
things off with a wide receiver we
talked about earlier in the show george
pickens comes off the board here
i think this is where you want george
pickens now i know that's a layup with
pat mahomes there the stretch the field
offense the ability to get creative andy
reed knows how to utilize guys
but for pickens size speed felder size
speed they lost tyree kill they did sign
mvs they did sign juju they are going to
spread the ball around a little bit more
but they still need a dude like this the
big bodied i can get over the top i can
find the ball and you can't run with me
down the field we know how much that
means to patrick mahomes lead offense
no i agree i i think he should be a
first rounder as well i just question if
he will be and that's one of those
things where you have to square
injury history
with production with why wasn't he on
the field at georgia and i think those
are behind closed doors things
where you're going to get a different
story from kirby smart then you're
probably going to get from george
pickens about why he wasn't in the game
and honestly more than anything i think
he can be a better at pro than he was at
georgia the question for me becomes what
is the difference the variance in those
stories between when you talk to kirby
smart about him and when you talk to
george pickens about kirby spark that's
my biggest question mark because i think
he's a first-round player he just didn't
have an opportunity to grow into that at
georgia
i'm with you felder i'm very curious to
see his landing spot and see if he's a
guy that just explodes onto the scene
that everybody looked around and said
man he was actually really good in
college he just got hurt the production
fell off a little bit and now he's ready
to rock all right the chiefs pick again
time for a little draft and stash i'm
going to throw out you felder david
ojabo here from michigan we also it
stinks that he got hurt on the pro day
yeah i think he'll be ready to rock in
the playoffs and i think for a chief's
team that desperately needs pass rush
i know ebay katie can be in play here i
know boy a mafia can be in play here
felder i'll go with the guy that has
been viewed as a top 15 20 player and
and deal with the injury and injury that
guys come back from quicker and quicker
year after year at this point i think at
jabbo frank clark chris jones the chiefs
will be cooking with something in a
conference that they're gonna run into
the playoff gauntlet of joe burrow josh
allen now desean watson it's not getting
any easier for kansas city you're gonna
have to deal with justin herbert in the
playoffs eventually russell wilson
this is the guy to me that i think has
the scary potential you just have to be
a little patient
yeah i i i listen i was wondering if we
were going to get a job but when you
sent me the email about this i was
scroll he was one of the names that i
did the control f4 to see if he hit and
i think that's the right spot for him uh
he's someone that obviously you
questioned uh how much was him how much
was aiden hudson but the reality of it
is is you're seeing him get it done by
himself right there uh one on one
winning that one-on-one battle you see
it again here uh maybe don't try to
maybe don't let him get that wide of a
release and be able to spin underneath
he's still learning and i think that's
the key for me he's still learning i
think he's going to be better i think
some time off will help him work on some
polish and get to watch a little more
tape even so yeah i love a java right
there uh for the chiefs uh what do we
want to get to the bengals now
let's get to the bengals we gave the
chiefs some love they had the
back-to-back picks they're going to be a
fun team to watch in this draft after
the tyre killed trade boosted their
draft capital but let's get to the
bengals here felder one of the hardest
teams to figure out in the draft because
they did such a good job in free agency
building this offensive line so i'm
going to go a little bit off the rails
here and i'm going to go with kyrie elam
a corner for them uh they brought back
eli apple on a one-year deal they have
invested a little bit in this position
but they're they're a team that plans to
be around in big games for the next five
years not the next year or looking back
at last year this is a we're gonna have
a long-term starter at the cornerback
position when we're gonna have a hole
there in 23. this gives him a little
time to go at his own pace and kyrie
illinois i'll say this 2020 when things
were clicking his tape was up there with
any other corner in the entire country
that year
yeah it's just about it clicking i mean
this is a big physical corner a guy that
wants to put hands on you wants to be
physical you see him here with the
running but this is a guy that's at his
best i think closer to you hands on you
bothering you not afraid to be active in
the run game so i want to see more of
that from him and i want to see them use
him that way where he's able to just be
physical you see him there out muscling
a bigger guy for the football so i'm
looking forward to i think this is great
i think this is fantastic if you're the
bengals and you can get elam at that 31.
you go ahead and you take it
i'll take us to the lions because you
got another guy that i absolutely love
uh we get to the lions and listen i'm
happy you slid another safety in here
because i love jaquan brisker
he is we mentioned dachshund hill as a
swiss army knife
i mean brisker this dude is a hammer and
the whole world's a nail when he's in
the game
we see him here look at him play up on
the line of scrimmage knife through go
make a play he's a guy that can play
we've seen him play too high safety
single high safety man safety come down
linebacker and covers zero you look at
me he's playing linebacker right here
don't worry i'm making a play he does
everything and he does it with bad
intentions connor
oh felder we love this guy on the show
and it's going to be one of those
moments on draft night that we're going
to be so happy to see where he goes
because what we saw this year was really
good and it was with one shoulder what
is it gonna be when he's healthy when
he's right when he can tackle like a
normal human not having to play with one
shoulder he's got so much meat on the
bone and coverage that you talk about
all the time he's somebody that is just
it's gonna he's such a good football
player he's gonna be such an impactful
player because he can handle any single
role you ask of him at safety and i
think he's gonna be a top 40 pick and if
that's after 32 it's going to be some of
the best value in the draft the lions
are going to be looking at safeties in
this draft though so 32 and 34. keep an
eye on this one
so i got i got some i love that for
brisker i love it i absolutely love it
two questions i have here so we're
looking at we're calling the dogs right
we got davis we got wyatt
we got um we got pickens
we got walker we got four dogs
no nakobi deed in the in the in the top
32 in the first round and then so i want
to get you your take on this one do you
think pickens really does go this early
and then where's my where's my guy in
the kobe d
man i'm with you so one on pickens and
shout out to lefko in the comments guys
i think the eagles are going to draft
jermaine johnson sorry lefko they have
to move up to get him i'd be really
surprised if he made it to 15. i think
baltimore likes him i think a lot of
teams in the top 10
are considering it but baltimore is the
problem there great to see lefko in the
comments can't wait to be with him
thursday and friday night in new york
city felder with pickens it's a little
all over the place right does he make
sense for somebody in the top 20 that
can't miss probably not the chiefs at 29
that they have juju there they have
valdes scantling there they can work him
in at their own level and he fits the
offense so much that's probably where it
starts
for george pickens i think realistically
you're going to see him more somewhere
in the first half of the second round
instead because of that lack of
production the kobe dean i'll say this
there's only two things that are going
to take nicoby dean out of round one and
i'm starting to think it's going to
happen as much as i don't agree with it
for me he's i think a top 20 player for
me in this draft when you look at the
board i met 19 ahead of his teammate
trayvon walker that's probably going to
go number one overall it's it's nuts
the the size which whatever we're seeing
linebackers get smaller and smaller and
smaller in the nfl which is a good thing
because you got to be able to run it's
as simple as that and these guys that
are 6'5 260 can't be in the middle of
the field anymore the second thing
felder that we're starting here a little
recently he didn't get to test i think
there's a lower body body injury in
there that you're at least wondering
about did it hold them back from just
testing or is it holding them back in
general those are things that it might
not matter by the time training camp
starts this happens all the time it just
happens to matter in april a little bit
where it could be the difference of you
going 24 and you might go 38 39 whatever
it may be uh nicole dean's a special
player
the instincts everything that you love
about them and i think it's it's going
to be fascinating to see
how do you
measure a guy that didn't test and is
small versus a guy that has
top 10 top eight tape in the entire
class
you you watch his film
that's it it's it it's all there he's
amazing it's all there i'm with you
felder
i'm with you all right guys well
let's get back to the comments one more
time to close out this show
um we had pete rodriguez say corral is
the most underrated quarterback in this
draft easily
you know with the quarterback situation
here felder i think corral is somebody
that
you know he's a little all over the
place the the college offense is it's
one thing that teams are looking at they
know there's a longer transition period
for corral the physical talent's really
good felder obviously pete says he's
underrated
what is what's too early for corral do
you think it's just the first round or
you think even top of the second round
there's just too much risk there
i think top of the second round is fine
for him he
high risk absolutely this is a guy
nobody in this class believes in their
arm more than matt corral
including a guy like a carson strong
who's also got a cannon or malik willis
who's also got a cannon but nobody
believes in it more than matt corral and
corral also is a time buyer right this
is a guy that's gonna find ways to steal
time by running around so i just i think
that
for him
he's high risk high reward but he's
somebody
he's he's like a athletic brett favre
right like this guy if he's your
starting quarterback he's probably gonna
throw 20 interceptions
and
but he's also going to yeah you deal
with it because he's also going to do
something like this or he's going to run
and and he's going to throw he's going
to make this throw right
not a lot of guys are going to make that
throw all the time not a lot of guys
feel confident enough to make that throw
this is a guy that just i mean he's
baffling
in a good way and sometimes in a bad way
like he can be his team's worst enemy or
he could be the hardest quarterback that
you play against and that's just the
reality with corral that up and down
football playing that that he brings to
the table
yeah he's truly somebody and we know
we're kind of
just beating this one into the ground
but these quarterbacks need seasoning
right whether it's malik whether it's
corral whether it's desmond ritter who's
a four-year starter so it's a little
weird to say but it's still a fact sam
howell these guys need time they're just
not up to speed
in what's going to function in an nfl
offense all right big baller brandon
says solid pick and elim wouldn't be
surprised if the bengals trade back a
few slots for extra third good call
teams at the end of the first round have
a much easier time getting out because
of the fifth year option and teams at
the top of the first round where the
cost is way too high
uh diesel really like the ojabo pig
achabo gonna be a solid player worth the
pick alonso soto says grab that fifth
year option on a jabbo as well
all right felder i think it's uh
we've had a lot of fun we've been mock
drafting for over an hour we're gonna be
real drafting in just a couple of days
so let's let's get to it we have the nfl
draft
our coverage one more time for everybody
watching please rock with us thursday
night at eight friday night starting at
6 50
days day three rounds four and five
felder and i will be with tory holt you
see days one and two there we'll have
richard sherman talking dbs jason kelsey
talking o-line i'm on ross st brown
talking wide receivers adam lefkow
hosting the show we cannot wait for
everybody that rocked with us for crash
course from the very first episode we
hope you're caught up to speed that's
the goal of the show we don't want you
to know the players we talked about
today pix1 through 32. we want you to
know the players we're going to be
talking about live in the bleacher
report out for round one two three four
and five i'm connor rogers the lead nfl
draft analyst here at bleacher report he
is michael felder the college football
analyst for stadium we'll see you
thursday night
[Music]
[Music]
foreign